alors nous sommes au pied d'un nouveau
robot
à ses débuts c'est le début parce
qu'effectivement nous avons une
augmentation des cas de contamination
nous avons aussi une accélération de
cette augmentation et ça définit le
rebond épidémique et la vague épidémique
maintenant on ne sait pas jusqu'à quel
niveau les contaminations guy roux et
pendant combien de temps cela va durer à
la professeure on nous avait dit parce
que comme toute chose il ya un an on
avait dit vous allez voir quand il fera
beau qui fera chaud de colite de
lui-même va disparaître et là c'est pas
le cas du tout alors qu'est-ce qui
excusez moi mais
comme toujours le doubs et son contraire
donc on est de plus en plus perdu il
fallait et il par exemple enlever les
masques dans les transports publics on
n'est qu'à nez à nez dans le métro par
exemple alors vous avez raison donc ce
qu'on a dit c'est que le coronavirus ne
disparaîtra pas de la planète il avait
dit vas y avoir des vagues successifs
alors même qu' on va dire on va
s'installer dans une période plutôt
endémique c'est à dire en fait un virus
qui circule à un niveau plus ou moins
prédéterminé de temps en temps alors
l'impression de deux à trois fois par an
une épidémie un peu plus marqué alors
heureusement pour nous l'immunité
collective qui a été on va dire renforcé
par la vaccination de la population
aujourd'hui une couverture en france de
80% mais également les différentes
infections antérieur est aujourd'hui
suffisants pour protéger la très grosse
majorité de la population contre les
risques graves de la maladie malgré tout
il y à des personnes plus fragiles à
risque qui elles peuvent développer des
formes plus grave alors et donc c'est ce
vers lequel on s'oriente avec
aujourd'hui de nouveau sous variant b à
4 et b à 5 on va dire moins virulent que
les variants historique c'est un mix du
du delta et du rhône alors non c'est
plutôt des variants au micron qui ont un
tout petit peu modifié leurs protéines
spahic c'est à dire la maman de leur
poêle à la croche qui permet d'interagir
cylindrée de l'infecté et dont qu'ils
arrivent à contourner un tout petit peu
le système immunitaire et à provoquer
des infections peu virulente la quasi
totalité des personnes alors tous les
gros qu'on se pose est-ce qu'il est plus
ou moins puisqu'il est plus ou moins
agressifs que les précédents alors les
études semblent
très qu'il est aussi peu virulent que b1
et b2 à nouveau dans une population
vaccinée wii ou ayant réactive une
immunité coller à la bhl à l'inversé
quelqu'un qui n'ait non vaccinés qui n'a
jamais rencontré le corona vide là il ya
des riads plus important plus important
pour me grave de la maladie
alors une autre question il paraît que
ce variant là il n'y a pas forcément des
formes pulmonaires mais ça tape un peu
partout à la fois le système digestif
les manifestations sont assez
différentes alors on va dire le tableau
est plutôt identique c'est-à-dire des
tableaux essentiellement d'infections
des voies aériennes supérieures donc des
maux de gorge difficulté à avaler une
fatigue des douleurs musculaires de la
fièvre
donc comme une sorte de petite grippette
alors il ya bien sûr des troubles
digestifs mais c'était déjà le cas avec
d'accord les formes antérieures donc par
contre oui effectivement ça atteint
essentiellement les voies aériennes
supérieures plus que le poumon pourquoi
parce que l'immunité que l'on a acquise
grâce à la mémoire immunitaire protège
le poumon et donc le virus pour pouvoir
se diffuser car à nouveau levier c'est
un être vivant lui cherche à se
développer donc quand il rencontre
l'immunité il s'adapte et plutôt que
d'aller essayer d'infecter le poumon et
de se heurter au système immunitaire il
a réservé une façon d'infecter les voies
aériennes supérieures qui sont moins
bien protégés par l'immunité acquise
ainsi il peut se multiplier beaucoup
faire rapidement est-ce qu'on n'est pas
un peu trop alarmiste avec ces nouveaux
variants est ce que les médias ne joue
pas un rôle là dedans parce que les gros
titres c'est toujours rebond épidémique
attention danger et quand on lit les
article c'est ok ya beaucoup de cas mais
pas de forme grave est ce que au final
ça ne joue pas sur la peur des gens et
ça fait paniquer les gens pour les
vacances est ce que les médias on joue
un rôle là dedans alors je ne crois pas
mais je crois qu'il est important
d'abord de signal à la population qu
effectivement le coronavirus n'a pas
disparu qu' il y à bien rebonds et pis
des milk maintenant l inverse je ne suis
pas persuadé en tout cas pour la période
estivale qui va y avoir la mise en place
de mesures de restriction des
déplacements ou des mesures de port du
masque rendu plus obligatoire dans un
certain nombre de lieux pourquoi parce
que à nouveau on est plutôt désormais
dans une phase de responsabilisation je
pense que tout le monde a bien compris
les risques les modes de contamination
et chacun a lui même d'évaluer
on va dire les dangers vis-à-vis de
lui-même et la façon dont il comprend et
donc il a peur du danger si
effectivement vous êtes jeunes en bonne
santé
vaccinés ya pas de risque et pas grand
chose donc à ce mois là bas vous grid
quasi normalement maintenant si vous
êtes plus âgé immunodéprimés avec des
comorbidités et bien même une infection
baigneurs oui eh bien elle peut dès
qu'on pense et d'autres maladies ça qui
demande au plus tôt en tentant de le
faire la quatrième dose alors je tapais
donc landes alors ça ça va être à mon
avis un critère important daniel roy
s'il faut généralement
gérant des on a rendez vous lundi mais
revient d'un repas 60 ans enfin pas tout
à fait c'est ce
qu'on appelle avant tout les personnes
âgées de plus de 60 ans non mais
également celles qui ont des
comorbidités magnifiques jeunes celles
qui sont ils une eau déprimé donc si
vous avez une maladie cash et actions
est déprimé donné que des primes et
servait alors les immunodéprimés le
problème avec des niveaux de prix mais
c'est que malheureusement ils répondent
mal à la vaccination ce n'est qu'il est
possible que pour certains notamment
ceux qui sont porteurs de greffes
d'organes alors même qu'il reçoit de la
4ème ou la 5ème doses de vaccin soit pas
d'immunité suffisant alors ces personnes
là sont à très haut risque lionel rabiet
comment se présentent les vacances plus
qu est-ce que vous dans votre secteur
vous êtes inquiet oh oui on est inquiet
inquiet par ce qui se passe actuellement
dans les aéroports puisqu'on est déjà on
est seulement j'ai envie de dire au mois
de juin il ya déjà aujourd'hui des temps
d'attentes qui peuvent être extrêmement
longue des avions qui sont annulés des
grèves qui menacent donc oui il n'y a
clairement fait la ville après que le
secteur du tourisme ce soit l'hôtellerie
les compagnies aériennes paye maintenant
locaux vides parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui a changé de boulot j'ai
entendu à feu à ryanair il ya un vrai
problème de personnel c'est le cas dans
d'autres compagnies un peu low cost les
gens veulent plus travailler de là où
j'étais avant fin avant que les pouilles
il ya eu un manque d'anticipation
peut-être du retour des de l'envié des
français de voyager mais ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on agisse puisque
on est on est encore au mois de juin à
la fin du mois de juin mais s'il n'est
pas trop tard nous ce qu'on demande
c'est que le gouvernement mette plus
d'effectifs dans les aéroports notamment
dans les services de douane de sécurité
les compagnies aériennes d'asie 3 à 4
heures pour passer les oui mais sans
formalités du cesi
table c'est insupportable mais gérard
baril préférons nous recommande
évidemment aux voyageurs de venir en
avance on a d'autres recommandations à
faire d'ailleurs mais je voulais dire
c'est pas trop grave de perdre une heure
ou deux heures de temps plutôt que ses
vacances donc oui il faut arriver en
avance nous aurons moi moi ce que je dis
aussi au passage et ceux qui vont à
roissy notamment charles de gaulle
prenez les transports en commun quand
c'est possible parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
avait gelé vécu là ya une semaine nous
arriver à l'aéroport vous avez une heure
d'attenté pour arriver jusqu'au terminal
il sourit c'est vrai donc et ça je peux
me dire que c'est un stress donc on leur
dit pas prenez les voyages et les
transports en commun si c'est possible
prenez une chambre à l'aéroport la
veille surtout si vous avez
vraiment short de en trésorerie et tout
ce qui s'est passé entre les restes si
en plus vous partir l'avait eu vent d'un
petit radisson il
[Musique]
faut prendre de l'avancé ce que pour
ceux qui n'ont pas encore réservé il
faut privilégier les géants veut dire
les voyageurs semaine c'est-à-dire du
mardi au mardi ou du mercredi au
mercredi parce qu on s attend on
s'attend à ce que les week-ends soudan
est très compliqué et aujourd'hui les
tours opérateurs les voyagistes
proposent de la même façon ces jours là
il faut prévoir des temps de
correspondance assez long voilà c'est la
réalité est-ce que vous avez constaté
votre niveau une vraie eau des prix on
parle de à wissant qui ont fait plus que
j'ai un souci quand il ya eu ce 40
pourtant il ya deux sujets il ya
vraiment deux sujets c'est le genre de
la hausse des prix de l'aérien
c'est très simple un rien plus vous
réservez tôt moins c'est cher il est
clair que si aujourd'hui 24 où j'ai
oubliée la date en tout cas fin juin
vous réserver pour le mois de juillet
évidemment que ça va coûter cher donc il
faut après il ya d'autres formes de
vacances qui peuvent être plus malins
mais s'agissant des restaurants
effectivement oui c'est un phénomène
global qui concerne pas que les vacances
oui mais benjamin on sait très bien que
pierre qui roule n'amasse pas mousse
on dépense de l'argent oui bien sûr bien
ça c'est ça que vous voulez arrêter ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des images ou des jeux qui passe son
temps entre la france et les antilles
oui ce qu elle est ambassadrice du
célèbre compagnie aérienne donc en plus
ça serait pas des billets oui mais pas
que tu as fait que les antilles
puisqu'elle revient de marrakech
d'ailleurs ça va
je vais voir des choses avec vous alors
la toute première ya une chose que j'ai
testé je pense que c'est un bon conseil
pour les gens pour sur des compagnies
low cost notamment que ça coûte pas trop
cher les fasse parce ça coûte en général
15 balles ça change la vie parce que
vous avez donc passer par les villes
quand vous êtes avec avec trois enfants
est comme ça fait cher des 15 plus qu'un
seul faux pas ni les bagages vous avez
mal à l'hôtel la veille voilà il n'ya
pas nécessairement les transports les
sociétés où ça se passe où la première
classe voilà c'est ça donc vaut mieux
prendre les phases d'action est d'accord
et moi je vais savoir parce que par
exemple là justement comme je vais
encore voyager cet été moi j'ai mon
schéma vaccinal complet est ce que ça
continuera nous suffire où est ce qu'on
va nous demander les tests pcr et tout
comme
mega man alors non ça devrait suffire
dakar par contre effectivement il faut
absolument les deux doses et la dose de
rappel c'est ça c'est ça qui est objet
toutes les doses dollars
est ce qu'on peut espérer bientôt qu'on
ne demande plus du tout de vaccin ce qui
est du coup plein de personnes qui n'a
pas voyagé pour cet été en est là c'est
ce que les pays de la communauté
européenne se sont mis d'accord que le
pass vaccinale sera encore il se dit bhl
peut voler voyage entre les pays lionel
est ce que les français enfin plutôt à
l'étranger
magret ou plutôt ses parts en espagne de
plus on reste en france non aujourd'hui
on voit vraiment un retour vers les
vacances à l'étranger d'un jour et
préciser une chose quand on parle des
vacances c'est plus d'un tiers des
voyageurs c'est ce qu'on appelle le me
dire les voyageurs ethnique c'est des
gens qui tout simplement vont retrouver
leur famille elles n'ont pas vu depuis
deux ans beaucoup dans les pays du
maghreb voilà c'est aussi ça
le voyage mais clairement oui on observe
une envie d'aller à l'étranger la france
c'est formidable mais voilà l'année
majoritairement enfants je suis homo
copine enfin personnellement je pense
est une excellente chose effectivement
que les pays demandent encore qu'ils
soient vaccinés parce que justement ça
nous protège par rapport à 7 à cette
résurgence et on peut se dire que
finalement quand on part en vacances
quand on prend l'avion et ben on est que
avec des gens qu'ils sont protégés comme
des plus 30 % oui buy -7 charentes
languedoc de 7 à 30 x tu dois ça va ça
arrive la côte d'azur benjamin pas être
portugal moins 30 de leurs pourquoi
maintenant nous
les avons pas l organe alors ce qu'il
faut voir aussi c'est que ce qu'on
observe c'est qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de ventes de dernière minute donc
typiquement les pays comme l'espagne le
portugal la grèce ou si on observe la
sur le mois de juin dd hausse très forte
de réservation donc je pense que ces
chiffres se seront seront un peu
inversée une pour le portugal j'ai
aucune explication mais mais comme il ya
plus d'avions et kader est partout c'est
compliqué de partir au portugal où il
n'y a pas partout mais mais c'est vrai
que fin aujourd'hui comme j'ai dit les
français son envie de partir en vacances
je pense qu'il faut qu'il ya un peu
entre à banias où sa maman unique c'est
gros ce contrat il ya eu pas de travail
pas d'avion il ya des grèves d'avion à
l'aéroport
je lance un appel à ce que ces
personnels à la tête le mois de
septembre ou le mois d'octobre pour
faire grève on a le droit d' on n'a pas
le droit de gâcher les vacances et
surtout cette année on n'a pas le droit
alors ça je pense que votre appel n'a
pas du tout étonnant qu'il y avait de le
faire vous avez montré le graphique la
côte d'azur + 30 % vous avez vu les prix
en côte d'azur que vous voulez si vous
voulez prendre un hôtel si vous louez
une voiture si vous voulez arriver sur
sa torpeur c'est plus 40% de tmc c'est
un enfer magali bout d'une amie qui m'a
trahie dans une autre
date à d'une amie qui travaille dans une
compagnie aérienne qui m'a dit que l'on
allait remettre des masques ma vision
est ce que c'est vrai maintenant alors
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de règlements
qui l'imposent vous avez encore quelques
compagnies qui le demandent mais de
moins en moins donc c'est vraiment
compagnie décider mais je m encore une
fois vous êtes dans un avion tourner
vacciner à peu près pour les
destinations vous avez une fils à son
père aujourd'hui on a après deux ans de
chaos vite on n'a aucun cluster d'un
avion
je prends souvent je pense souvent des
vols espagne paris
malgré ma copine habite en espagne et
l'espagne par exemple c'est un pays qui
attire beaucoup les français et bien
c'est un pays qui a décidé qu ont
continué à mettre le mas alors dans les
avions bien on serait le fils 1h01
fischer qui connaît ce n'est pas
recommandé et je pense qu'il a pas
complètement tort de remettre
volontairement le masque dans les
transports en commun c'est bon on est
comme ça c'est quand même plus prudent
regarde là c'est les véhicules ben non
on marche sur la tête les transports est
ce que vous le souhaitez je pense que ça
se discute sérieusement
à titre personnel je sais pas
strictement mon champ d'action je pense
que dans les transports collectifs c'est
probablement raisonnable il faudrait
leur est imposé certainement pour les
personnes fragiles et je dirais
probablement pour l'ensemble des blocs
population parce que c'est une mesure de
protection collective et quand on a en
faisant le petit effort de porter le
masque ou contribuer à protéger les
personnes fragiles pour ses 10 ans et
les noirs plus rapide de ces paris
l'enlever le mas dans les transports en
commun non je ne crois pas je crois
qu'il faut vivre ça l'est voilà je re
vivre normalement tout à fait il faut
quand même de plus en plus arriver à
vivre normalement maintenant lorsque
l'on est dans une phase où l'épidémie
est importante où le virus circule façon
très large
galles en angleterre en france
apparemment c'est ça repart quand même
oui c'est quasiment dans tous les pays
dans tous les pèlerins et en amérique
aussi beaucoup voilà maintenant comme on
l'a expliqué ce n'est pas pour autant
une raison de généraliser le masque à
tout le monde par contre c'est un moment
important pour rappeler que le virus
existent et surtout pour rappeler aux
personnes les plus fragiles donc plus de
60 ans immunodéprimés avait co
morbidités elle de faire très attention
effectivement dans les milieux clos
public comme les transports en commun
mal aérée il vaut mieux mettre un masque
et puis surtout faire sa fameuse dose de
rappel et on voit d'ailleurs depuis
quelques jours augmenté de façon très
importante cette fameuse quatrième dose
de rappel néanmoins il persiste donc ces
100 millions de personnes en france
éligible à cette dose de rappel cette
deuxième dose de rappel qui ne sont
toujours pas vaccinées et ceux ci
courent un certain risque est ce que
l'hôpital a eu le temps de se
réorganiser ou est-ce que ça va être oui
s'il ya encore un danger de du fait
qu'il faudrait qu'ils soient bien
dépasser vous avez raison c'est stop
c'est le deuxième point avec la
généralisation de la deuxième dose de
rappel aux personnes éligibles c'est le
deuxième point critique que vont
surveiller les autorités sanitaires pour
décider si oui ou non il faut mettre un
certain nombre de mesures de frais
nations comme le port du masque dans les
transports en commun alors aujourd'hui
l'hôpital n'est pas sous pression il
faut certes 800 personnes en rien
aujourd'hui à peu près mais il faut
savoir que on commence à voir un
frémissement sur les entrées en
hospitalisation conventionnel que ça va
augmenter comme ça a été le cas au
portugal malheureusement il y aura une
augmentation aussi de la mortalité
notamment chez les personnes âgées mais
comme vous le savez l'hôpital public
souffre depuis maintenant plusieurs
années d'un manque de personnel
chronique d'une fermeture de lits avec
un nombre de lits inadapté aux besoins
de santé de la population et en plus
c'est l'été donc il va y avoir un
certain nombre de deux amis dans
l'avenir en vacances il ya plus serré
les accidents de la route sur ya
quelques maladies comment l'estival
d'anthologie ces cinq ans et voilà tout
à fait ce qu'a fait donc ça peut quand
même il peut y avoir un risque il malgré
tout je ne valais pas que on va dire il
ya un danger et une menace immédiate par
contre le vrai danger s'il en existe un
ce sera la rentrée en octobre ses
professeurs franchement je le dis vous
nous déprimer non c'est un jour seront
fermés chaque année on va
supporter les sens et c'est le propre de
excusez moi je ne sors plus tant de
morts avec le co vie d'aujourd'hui
par jour non ça n'a évidemment journée
est ce que je vois avec d'autres
maladies par exemple de deux comptes en
fait il faut pas tout simplement
accepter cette maladie est peut-être se
dire que ben qui a des maladies qui sont
même encore plus dangereuses et pourtant
on n'arrête pas de vivre à cause de ses
mines tout à fait mais je n'ai à aucun
moment émis un message qui s'arrête
parce que je me rends compte j'émets un
message de précaution de prévention
vis-à-vis de la population qui elle un
risque de décéder et donc quand vous
avez 70 80 vous êtes tous en bonne santé
c'est dommage d'être infecté par un
petit virus et de finir en réanimation
est malheureusement de moore et alors et
tous les jours il y à 75 décès en france
un certain nombre à tout et part en tête
évitables ou simplement dit des quelques
conseils pour ceux qui me regardent pour
essayer d'améliorer l'ordinaire pour les
vacances ce qui est le propre des trucs
qu'on pourrait donner pour essayer de
trouver le bon plan le bon endroit où
est-ce que c'est foutu et il ya plus de
veille et tout est trop cher un an pour
ce qu'on peut encore réserver je dire il
faut sortir des sentiers battus alors je
pensais par exemple un bon plan ça
pourrait être de faire une croisière au
départ de marseille qui vous permet de
voir l'espagne l'italie et plein
d'autres pays c'est même pas besoin de
prendre l'avion c'est pas trop cher ça
ah non non c'est pas trop cher pas si
encore encore des cartes ici pas trop
cher trop cher c'est 700 ou 800 euros
dans une semaine
je vous dis donc ça ça c'est un vrai bon
plan après il ya des déceptions des rats
copains cariou tout si ça peut aider ça
c'est un autre
il ya dans destination que l'on pense
pas forcément comme malte comme chypre
qui est offre j'en veux dire les mêmes
les pêcheurs palma de majorque est assez
à céder quand même non c'est pas cher
mais il ya beaucoup de signes malte mal
par exemple à des plages extraordinaire
chypre aussi ça coûte moins cher c'est
il ya un peu moins de monde quand même
que quand la grèce actuellement qu'en
espagne